on va rester combien de temps déjà on
avait dit qu'on serait revenu pour la
remise des diplômes
il ya un autre résidence de montagne
comptiez la vente renom faudra
simplement à la libérer les dimanches
pour les portes ouvertes
c'est chouette de voir de nouvelles
têtes
tu dois être léogâne dans les petites
villes du monde se connaît je suis
absolument navré pour votre mari j'ai
perdu mon mari il y a quelques arguments
faux
et l'arrivée puis une fois qu'elle est
là et refuse de s'en aller
bon voilà on a regardé partout y'a
personne il y a eu des portes ouvertes
ici il ya quelques jours
peut-être que quelqu'un a trouvé une clé
dans un tiroir peut-être même qu'il est
encore ici
peut-être que des gamins sont entrés
pour faire une plaisanterie aux nouveaux
voisins
ça ressemblait pas une blague et bonjour
comment tu peux te sentir en sécurité
ici à l'eau il ya quelqu'un c'est
toujours bien d'avoir une connaissance
palois silence de ces lui est parfois un
sur deux
[Musique]
k